this herbal remedy is proving popular in
the battle against carbon 19 but with no
proof it actually works
Madagascar's president andre Rosalina
says it's so effective
he's exporting it to the other side of
the continent Guinea for sales president
is also impressed he visited the airport
to welcome the new shipment this
donation is a gesture in the fight
against the global pandemic called cope
it 19 I'd like to say what this Guinea
Bissau will be seen in a very different
concept of nationhood it will be seen as
a country that always has good people
and today the world will talk about
Guinea Bissau it's the second country to
have imported it the hub which is use as
a tonic contains the Artemisia plant
which is normally used to treat malaria
but the World Health Organization warns
that the effectiveness of the herb has
not been proven or even tested by
scientists but that hasn't stand its
popularity Tanzania's president says
he's in talks with Madagascar to send a
plane to collect a shipment take a
sample
we are already in touch with Madagascar
they wrote us an official letter
informing us about their cure we shall
send our airplane to go and pick the
drugs so our citizens can also reap the
benefits Tanzania has recorded 17 deaths
but the government's been accused of
failing to take the virus seriously in
the capital Darussalam it's business as
usual schools are shut but markets
mosques and churches remain open and
back in Madagascar the army has been
knocking door-to-door to give the tonic
to the most vulnerable people the
country is so far recorded few cases and
no fatalities but government actions
have gone beyond the herb masks whirring
and social distancing rules have been
enforced measures medical experts say
are effective even if the tonic is not
nor about a man the al-jazeera